alors vous êtes la cliente idéale à nous
pour un anti portrait chinois vous
décédez mais c'est vraiment mais ils ont
répété le nom c'est un vrai public de
télévision on perd vraiment regarder ils
ont répété la plomberie cas aujourd'hui
attention de la blu drucker
par exemple et de sylla
c'est un vrai public de télévision je
prête si vous étiez un défaut si vous
étiez un accident un accident médiatique
des versions la fois ci nous font une
guerre
le procès de jeanne d'arc à mener contre
6 ans que les juges dise la vertu une
trahison se mentir à soi-même une arme
amour un supplice le vide une cicatrice
les aides de zorro qui fait sur le
ventre des méchants un poison l'opium
si vous étiez un assassin et ben c'était
pas bien de le dire mais moi je suis
tout à fait sérieusement pour
l'euthanasie donc je serais pour aller
tuer des gens qui ont envie de crever et
je le ferai si c'est une torture idem
c'est une injure
je twitte à merde au cou
désir
écrit par de la mission